michel desjoyeaux est donc le grand
vainqueur de ce vendée globe pour
remporter cette épreuve il a réalisé un
véritable sans faute sur tous les océans
desjoyeaux et ce soir un héros ses
premières impressions ont été recueillis
par l'équipe de thalassa a lors d'une
émission spéciale sur notre chaîne
le skipper breton vivait alors ses
derniers instants à bord on les écoute
j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir pendant 93
jours mais là j'avoue que en quelques
minutes
j'en ai le centuple autres je vais pas
me priver de de la fête c'est seulement
impressionnera voir la remontée de
l'atlantique à booker en passant le horn
français qu il me restait qu'à rentrer à
la maison
et heureusement la durée du parcours du
vendée globe a sévi une fois de plus
avec des mystères comme hélène une jeune
fille navigatrice et un anticyclone de
son état qui m'ont donné du fil à
retorde ces deux là mais je ne regrette
rien
est ce que en contraste avec ces images
de rentrée du sable de la ligne les
images qui vous reviennent sur les
moments de solitude dans cette course
les moments dans certains océans moment
de solitude j'ai pas je vais pas le
sentiment d'avoir souffert de solitude
parce que tous les jours on appelle à la
maison tous les jours on a des nouvelles
de ce qui se passe sur terre tous les
jours on a je dire on est on est en
relation permanente avec les avec
d'autres gens que ce soit ma famille que
ce soit une régine que ce soit mon
attachée de presse qui ces deux
personnes m'ont énormément soutenu
pendant tout ce tour au quotidien et
dans tous les moments forts ils étaient
là ils ont toujours trouvé les mots que
pour me tenir
le garder motivés et m'aider à passer
les moments durs des moments durs y en a
tellement que je pourrai pas vous en
raconter mais il ya aussi tellement de
bons moments que c'est ces 93 jours qui
marqueront un mémoire à tout jamais
c'est clair c'est c'est plein d'émotions
j'en ai presque les larmes aux yeux le
meilleur c'est ça qui est génial dans la
navigation en solitaire et c'est ça que
j'aime bien c'est qu'on est vraiment
face à sako qui tous les matins va tous
les matins vous tous les soirs où tous
les jours 24 heures sur 24
il ya vraiment aucun temps mort et et on
est seul à se démerder tous les
problèmes majeurs même si on a parfois
des conseils oraux
l'énergie qu'il a fallu dépenser pendant
les quatre jours après la panne de
démarreur
ça a été des moments très durs pour moi
mais le jour où le moteur redémarre pas
ce qu'on a trouvé la solution parce que
on a une imagination qu'il fallait au
bon moment c'est tellement génial
d'entendre un bruit de moteur alors que
le reste du temps le haïssait tellement
s'est brouillée on est tellement ça ça
gâche le plaisir d'être en navigation à
la voile sur des superbes machines que
sont ces monocoques
c'est surtout ça le vendée globe c'est
indescriptible
avec cet exemple est ce que parmi vos
enfants il avait déjà qu'ils sont partis
sur une route vers la voile
l'aîné à 8 ans les deux autres ont cinq
enfants des jumeaux moi ce que je leur
souhaite septième dans la vie ce qui ce
qui leur fait plaisir j'ai la chance
d'être en vacances depuis 35 ans et
c'est tout le mal que je leur souhaite
de faire pareil qu'ils fassent de la
voile ou qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils
veulent ça m'est égal
tant qu'ils le font avec amour avec
passion et que ça leur fait plaisir